Kobe's insane Bounty revealed the crazy
secret behind sword more mind-blowing
devil fruits and GARP destroys the
Blackbeard pirates in this epic chapter
so make sure to stay tuned for that
trailer parking with an ant smash that
like button if you enjoyed these chapter
reviews and want to keep them coming
make this the video you joined to not
come up by subscribing and hitting that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications so you don't miss future
one piece videos and updates now let's
jump into chapter 1080 called the
legendary hero this chapter starts on
pirate island with a bang I love how we
have so much intense interesting stuff
happening right now and I'm genuinely
interested in every Side Story often
even more so than in what the straw hats
are doing right now with cp0 let me know
what your most hype event going on right
now is and you can count Shanks wrecking
kid as he did last chapter as well we
see Kobe's wanted poster which is hype
because it is the first time we are
about to find out a Marine's Bounty I've
been hyped about the idea of Marines
having bounties now for a while and I've
been desperately waiting to get one and
Kobe's did not disappoint he has shown
with 5 stars on his poster we have heard
that Kobe was captured by Blackbeard so
it's not surprising that we see Kobe as
a prisoner carrying what looks like a
heavy ball and chain we also learned how
crossgale has their own system for the
Bounty number which I thought was a cool
touch Kobe's Bounty is 5 stars and one
star equals 100 million berries so
Kobe's Bounty is actually an impressive
500 million berries usually a marine
Captain has a bounty of one star but
because Kobe has the hero title for the
Marines his Bounty is much higher than a
normal Marine Captain love to see Kobe
making a name for himself too but it
obviously makes sense that his Bounty
wouldn't be close to as high as Luffy's
but besides that I feel like Marine
bounties may be lower overall because I
can't see them putting 40 stars to the
Note 4 billion berries on one poster
even if it's for like sakazuki but who
knows maybe they just make the Stars
smaller either way it would make sense
that they have less money to throw
around than the world government Kobe is
shown running from other Pirates acting
as a decoy taking attention away from
the other prisoners although Blackbeard
doesn't seem to be presently here we do
see that shiryu avalo Pizarro and Vasco
shot are here keeping an eye out on
things since Pirate Island is after all
Blackbeard's base since he became the
boss of it we see Pizarro emerging from
the ground to communicate with shiru
it's revealed that he has the shimashima
no me aka the island island fruit we
know Blackbeard wants to collect the
best devil fruits so I always look
forward to the reveals of his Pirates
fruits in this case the island island
fruit allows Pizarro to merge with
different things on the island like the
wooden floor or stone wall this lets him
easily go from talking to shiryu to
talking with Vasco shot in the next
panel it looks like Pizarro doesn't want
to intervene because he doesn't want to
wreck the town right after they finish
repairing the rocky Port this is a
loaded comment for a number of reasons
one it references the hype Rocky Port
incident one more time the incident that
law participated in that made be a hero
and that helped Blackbeard become the
new boss of pirate island Oda keeps
referencing it to the point where we
desperately need a flashback to it to
see what exactly happened another reason
that statement is significant and even
funny is because of what GARP is about
to do after he shows up but more on that
Insanity in a bit Vasco shot I must say
has a fitting devil fruit he has the
gabu-gabu no me aka the liquor licker
fruit Vasco so far is shown to be able
to make liquor Bubbles and fly on them
he says he wants to burn the town
altogether the Blackbeard Pirates having
different opinions is nothing new since
Blackbeard seems to have sacrificed
Unity for raw power like rocks the zebek
and Oda keeps emphasizing that I'm sure
it will come into play and mess them up
at some point we just don't know when
we've seen one panel that Pizarro can
really get ridiculously big now using
his new island Powers it's also notable
that San Juan wolf is here and
hilariously enough he's just sleeping
through it all only these four shiryu
Vasco Pizarro and wolf are on hachinosu
AKA Pirate Island holding down the fort
so to be fair this is not the full force
of the Blackbeard Pirates but what's
about to happen will still hurt their
reputation big time so as mentioned Kobe
is running now and the situation is
explained through flashback in more
detail we see when Kobe was tied up in
front of Blackbeard cools on and Van
auger among others Blackbeard wants to
make pirate island a kingdom approved by
the world government and he wants to be
the king this guy is always making
strategic moves with purpose turns out
he didn't just want Kobe's Bounty or to
have him as a vague bargaining chip but
he purposely kidnapped him to extort the
world government however the plan
doesn't go according to plan Kobe
explains he's part of sword and we're
about to find out more important
information about what that actually
means Kobe says that they can't use him
for negotiation since he is a member of
Sword kuzan then chimes in a dude who a
lot of the fandom expects is also a
secret member of sword and explains that
sword members are Marines who officially
reside as a result they can attack yonko
without approval and they are not bound
to chains of command but at the same
time the Marines take no responsibility
for them and can cut them off anytime a
very interesting reveal and it makes
these marines look so much cooler since
they aren't just dogs of the Marines who
need to follow commands at all times
once again more gray areas created by
Oda to complicate the distinction
between marine and pirate it is notable
that kusan got an exclamation mark over
his head when Kobe spoke meaning him
revealing he's part of Sword seems to
have surprised kuzan he also explains
exactly how sword works for Blackbeard
so not saying it's impossible but all of
this makes it less likely that he's a
current member of Sword like I said
before I don't want him to be a member
of Sword because that would not only
hurt the power of the Blackbeard Pirates
and we want them to be strong for the
final fight it would also be too obvious
and predictable it's notable that kuzan
is physically to the right of Blackbeard
here like a right-hand man making it
look like they are very close despite
all of this new information Blackbeard's
still believes he can use Kobe's hero
title to pressure the world government
and oh boy he has no idea how that
pressure is about to backfire on him
it's revealed that perona found Kobe in
a cell and told him she would release
him if he helped her release morya who
is in a deeper cell Kobe accepted and
that's why he's serving as a distraction
and helping to release other prisoners
as well now we see other members of
Sword too who have come to Pirate Island
it's been interesting just sticking to
one place in this chapter since I'm used
to Oda switching back and forth but I'm
definitely liking it because this is
some very interesting stuff and it's
only going to get more interesting as
the chapter goes on as they are
attacking Pirate Island some members are
introduced and we get even more crazy
devil fruit power reveals we see some
members of Sword get cut and then it's
revealed that their body is made of clay
currently and they just regrow from
their injuries how this is possible will
be explained shortly and it's crazy the
implications are crazy but first we see
moving buildings these powers are truly
insane it turns out that we're Admiral
kuchaku vice admiral turu whose
granddaughter is a muchimuchi user AKA a
whip whip user she can command
everything she whips including buildings
and she uses that power to trap the
Pirates in the middle of the island then
Commander he buddy steps in a sniper who
uses vegapunk's GP flower bullets that
turn enemies gunpowder to flowers so
they can't hurt Kobe who's in the middle
of all of these trap Pirates then we see
the really cool prince groose who is a
gunyogunyo user AKA clay clay user so
not only can he control clay it seems as
we saw that he can turn even fellow
swordmember bodies into clay so that
they won't be hurt by physical attacks
in battle at least not by the ones not
imbued with hockey as if this chapter
wasn't already crazy enough we then see
tashigi helmeppo with GARP but while the
former two are panicking as their ship
flies into the sky GARP Simply Smiles
it's one of the most epic entrances when
the Pirates and even Kobe below see the
seemingly flying ship appear above its
legendary stuff even though age-wise
Garfield should be past this Prime at 78
you'd never guess it after this chapter
GARP is laughing and seemingly crying
tears of joy whereas shiru and Vasco are
now definitely paying attention Garb
jumps off the ship and punches down on
the ground using an insane punch attack
called Galaxy impact his insane hockey
infused punch destroys the entire town
below way before he even comes close to
reaching it and his line is great he
says do you know who you kidnap Kobe is
the future of the Marines and my beloved
Apprentice like I said Blackbeard really
messed up by getting GARP this serious
and motivated at least it looks that way
for now it's funny that some earlier
spoilers made it sound like Garb took
out the Blackbeard pirates in one attack
my brother actually brought that to my
attention but I knew that was too much
it would have embarrassed the black hood
Pirates way too much especially after
all of that build up and lo and behold
it wasn't all of the Blackbeard pirates
only four and I'm sure they're all still
alive and gonna try to count their next
chapter now if Blackbeard planned for
this and somehow manages to use GARP
showing up in his favor then that will
raise his reputation and esteem to no
end and make him more than final
antagonists worthy to be sure but right
now it's hard to believe that the four
Blackbeard Pirates will be able to do
much on their own against all of these
sword members and the insane GARP whose
attack that we just saw despite his age
is arguably the most epic and Powerful
one we've seen in the series perhaps
this age will mean he can't last long
stamina wise or something but man the
power is there oh my god there will be a
break next week but again Oda left us
with an epic chapter to hold us over
until the next one comes out which I
always appreciate however the Blackbeard
Pirates as a whole do arguably have a
good chance even against GARP and if you
want to know why you don't want to miss
my every Blackbeard Pirate and their
powers explained video linked to that is
on screen right now and in the
description see you there